[Music]
mary's in hartford connecticut hi mary
welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave thank you for taking my call and
thank you rachel for for listening in on
on this too
so my question my husband and i are in
our early 60s and thank you
that to you and and to your plan that we
paid off 200 000
in two years by selling things but we
were debt-free january one of this year
wonderful thank you so much for that
yeah my my question because we hope to
retire in the next two or three years
um i'm nervous about investing in my
401k because every time i turn around
it's going down and down and down should
i use that money instead
just temporarily to help pay off our
mortgage
no
[Laughter]
how old are you mary 60s early 60s oh so
no yeah early 60s yeah i thought you
said 36 no early 60s
um and we make it we can make a good
income we're about 300k um before taxes
how much is in your ferrari
i have
um last i looked it was
389 000. okay what's your total nest egg
and it
husbands yours everybody
um
well we have 43 000 in our emergency
fund
um we have probably about another 30 000
in savings and checking
and and that's it
your 401k is the only one your husband
doesn't have one
that's right that's right you have a
penalty in our home
i have a small does he have a pension no
he does he does not have a pension okay
so you've got four let's just call it
four hundred thousand dollars and how
much is your mortgage okay
um our what we have left on our mortgage
is 315 thousand
zillow has i just looked at zillow and
it is estimated to almost a million
which is crazy
amazes me but it was yeah so you're a
millionaire 195 000 your baby step man
right but i'm
nervous about i i don't want to retire
with the mortgage good i don't want you
to retire with a mortgage either so um
let's lay out a plan on the mortgage for
a second uh how far how many years more
are the two of you going to work before
you want to how many years have we got
to pay off the mortgage
well
i would i would like to be able to
retire in two years and and perhaps for
my husband another four years okay and
how much of the 300 does he make
he makes 250. oh he makes the majority
of the income
yes yes yes okay and so in four years if
you paid off seventy five thousand a
year out of three hundred income the
mortgage would be paid off right
yes
yeah
without having to touch with that and
you could still put fifteen percent of
your income into retirement and baby
step four
but i want you to put on your your magic
hat again and predict me when the
market's going to rise up again i i
can't but the market's not crashing
the market is down 5
in the last 12 months
five percent
five percent is not going to keep you
from retiring
as a matter of fact it means that you're
at the store and they just announced a
sale over the intercom
the shirt you wanted to buy is on sale
mary
this is not the time to not buy the
shirt
all right
the stock market when it's down five
percent it's on sale you don't want to
buy it when it's up you want to buy it
when it's down
okay
all right it's still it's still scary
it's fearful my numbers are down you're
fearful it is scary but let's understand
five percent
of 400 000 down is not gonna cause you
to be able to retire or not be able to
retire you don't have a five percent
issue
okay if you have a 50 issue if your 400
went to 200
like if you're invested in bitcoin it's
down 50 percent
yeah and you're 400 which you're not
crazy so you didn't do that but i mean
you if you
you would be down to nothing right
i mean and you'd be down to half and so
we're not talking about that we're
talking about five percent and five
percent of four hundred thousand dollars
is eight thousand bucks
it looks a lot bigger when i look at my
statements it looks a lot bigger when
you listen to the news
the news is going to the right wing news
is going to do everything they can to
talk about how horrible the economy is
until the fall
because they're trying to get the
democrats thrown out of office
and the biggest thing that can get a
politician thrown out of office is the
economy so they're going to talk about
inflation they're going to talk about
recession they're going to talk about
high gases they're going to talk about
high interest rates they're going to
talk about how horrible things are and
the stock market is crashing
and they're going to you if you keep if
you keep the right wing news on you're
going to see that from now until fall
every it's going to be a steady beat of
that for the next six months
you're going to get a diet of it and
it's going to drive you bananas
i'll turn it off and if you watch the
left-wing news they lie about it on the
other way so
these things that that you know the
right wings are saying are true but
they're they're overstated like when a
tornado is coming through they tell
everybody they're going to die
it's the same thing because they're
trying to get ratings
okay but let me say this though when she
does look at the statement
and she sees oh that's what we lost like
it is it's a punch in the gut yeah so
mary though but what i would encourage
you is you know well i mean but she's
close to retirement so she is looking
she's got she's not going to use the
400. that's what i was going to say
though is that at that point you kind of
just put it away
and not sit there in this like rat race
cycle that you have
let it play out because you're going to
still be in the market
for another you know that's a good point
you're not going to use the 400 when you
retire yeah you're just going to live
off the income increase right
and so if it's up 8 000 or down 8 000 it
doesn't matter just keep it okay and so
watching the statement month in and
month out i'm 61. i don't look at my
statement not because i'm emotionally
incapable of doing it but i just don't
bother because i'm really not going to
use that money right now and the current
problems in the world are not going to
bother me one way or another because
that money i'm not going to use it right
now mary's in the same situation she's
not going to use that money she's going
to use the income off of that money
right
and so i would be more concerned
for her
if i thought the 500 000 or 600 or 700
000 that'll be by the time they get to
retirement
would not create an income for them yes
if the uh if there was not good returns
on that to live off of the returns
of that money that would concern me more
yes then the actual
amount going up or down five percent
how much income will it create over time
that's what i'm worried about that's a
that's a good way of understanding it
but yeah mary it's normal to do this i i
just i really turn off the news and i
quit looking at your statement every
month and it's not to be ignorant but
it's your it's driving you nuts
and uh it would probably drive me nuts
actually i don't i had to turn off the
news and i don't look at my statements
so there you go this is
[Applause]